good morning John they say that you
can't judge a book by it's cover but I
say you can't not judge a book by it's
cover that's what the cover is for
there's a reason that this book and this
book and this book all look kind of
identical like take a real fast of
fantasy novels right you can tell
because there's like chiseled words over
high contrast illustrations and all the
fonts have serifs oh my gosh look at
baby Neil Gaiman he's so boom that
looked different but very similar but
it's saying Sarah thought so it's sci-fi
that's the difference of obvious reasons
I've been thinking a lot about bill
covers lately I want to share with you
today the cover of my book an absolutely
remarkable thing it's available
September 25th and you can get it for
pre-order now but first I'd like to give
like a deeply subjective and incomplete
list of some of the best book covers
from the last 10 or 15 years let's start
here with a book that came out in 1986
but I promise it's gonna make sense it
is this is watchman if you've read the
comic you know what this image is if you
haven't then you probably don't and I
like that a lot about it it's mysterious
but it's bold and eye-catching
so bright and I like the bold very sort
of logo design alternate title placement
I mean obviously iconic one of the most
iconic covers ever but it's not really
one of the things on my list this is
this is it devours by Joseph Fink and
Jeffrey Cranor when I first saw it I
thought of the cover of Watchmen
obviously the color but also the really
sort of bold comic Aoife I love this
image I love that there's a lot of like
radial interesting things happening in
covers right now there's another really
good interesting radially design thing
and I also like that in this case the
title kind of becomes the cover rather
than there having to be some external
design element now maybe this is gonna
be a little bit surprising I don't
generally tend to like photographic
covers but the pale white arms and this
bright red centerpiece of this like
lovely pure thing that you really is the
kind of thing that you'd like to take a
bite out of the color scheme here
obviously was imitated a lot and I also
really liked the tiny 'no subtitle at
the in significance of the the title and
the author name that's a bold choice and
and like maybe you didn't expect to see
Twilight today but there it is let's go
more recent Simon vs. the Homo sapiens
agenda' I like this book cover so much
again bold color choices something I'm a
huge fan of there was a trend for a long
time in young adult fiction to chop
people's heads off and I think the idea
was like give people
yet that covers something to relate to
but not too much is does that in a
really interesting way and also it is
reminiscent of allure evolves on a
similar sort of cloud-based handwritten
font thing which leads me to one of the
like I might be a little bit biased here
but one of the best covers from the last
ten years this was such a departure and
when Rodrigo Corral made this for The
Fault in Our Stars I feel like it really
leveled up young adult literature it
feels kind of almost branded and I think
that it started off or was part of a
really important and necessary trend in
cover design a second to last cover of
East Rob's
a darker shade of magic again really
interesting thoughtful color choice
happening here as covered to me feels
kind of full of institutional knowledge
like it knows a great deal about the
book that I don't know yet I like that
about it and finally the last thing on
my list Papa Papa Papa Papa is the cover
of my blood I realized that I'm biased
but that's okay I think I have the
cutest cat in the world too it's not
like I designed it I had minimal input
it was a very scary process and I'm so
happy that I'm happy with what happened
to me this thought feels very like pulp
it feels adventure it feels comic but
then in the background here it feels
like you're getting drawn into something
that's a little bit mysterious a little
bit creepy which is exactly what I
wanted like it feels a little bit
ostentatious and it's color choice which
if you know the main character of the
book which none of you do yet that makes
a lot of sense April is a graphic
designer herself the main character in
the book and I she's very into color
choices I think that she'd be into how
it kind of stands on its own as a design
and a little bit of you know what
identity for the all of the
english-language publishers really like
this so it's gonna be the same cover in
the UK and Canada in Australia I look as
I cover John I'll see you on Tuesday